What they showed in some of the recent
work is that you run into problems if
you try to minimize the loss function
that we talked about which is
trying to minimize the kind
of GTD error directly.
And instead, you actually get something
that's much more well behaved if you
incorporate the function approximation
itself into the last function.
So take advantage of the fact that we
know that we're changing parameters
that are alternately going to influence
a linear representation of the function.
And then through that linear
representation the function that that's
where we're going to
actually measure the loss.
And so the projection with respect
to the function approximate or
ends up showing up in the last function
and that makes things happier.
>> Nice, well done.
So we had successes we had problems and
then we have successes
again it's pretty good.
>> Yeah and one of the thing to
note on the successes side is that
the current We can talk about this so
much but the go to algorithm these
>> Is called fitted Q iteration,
which is a way of mixing
function approximation and
Q value learning together.
Again, if [LAUGH] it has the same
kinds of problems, it need not work,
it need not converge,
it can behave really badly, but
this is something that a lot of
people have gotten to work decently.
So if you're you know if you're trying
to solve these kinds of problems this is
this is the go to.
GTD is not quite there yet
it's more of theoretical interest but
the hope is that these will actually
come more together in the future.
And there's one other topic that we that
we spent time on that I think is worth
mentioning which is
the notion of Averagers.
>> Yes.
>> And
the cool thing about an Averager was
not only where things well behaved
you got convergence with
a function approximater,
but it actually could be viewed
as a kind of MDP itself.
The function approximater or could be
viewed as kind of MDP itself which,
let's us get all kinds of nice
properties like that there's a unique.
Value function that it
needs to converge to.
One thing we didn't talk about
that's also really related to this
this topic is in the Averagers case we
have a set of anchor points for that?
>> Yes I do.
>> As the number of anchor
points increases, the error
in the value function approximation
that you get actually goes down.
And so you can actually converge
over time on not only an answer but
actually the right answer,
the right value function in the limit.
>> Right because this is just K and
N, or was a lot like K and N.
And that would be true for
canon as well.
>> Yes.
>> Alright if you had
an infinite number of points for
example you could actually
represent the point.
>> So in optional reading we'll actually
put a link to it to the first paper
that really goes through that
argument and shows that.
Yeah in fact as the amount of data
increases things like averages kernel
methods converge to the optimal value
function the true value function.
>> That's pretty cool, so
that everything we learn
including stuff we did learn?
>> I think that's
everything we learned and
a bunch of things that we didn't learn,
and
then I probably should also just
say LSPI and just leave it at that.
>> [LAUGH] I think that's right we
have to leave them to go learn something
on their own or those with a point B.
>> Yes.
Least squares policy iteration,
which is which is a kind of linear
function approximation where
policy improvement is actually
incorporated into the system itself, and
it has some super nice properties and
people have gotten it to do good things.
The tricky thing is always the feature
set, getting the right features so
that linear function
approximation does an okay job.
>> Well it's always true, isn't it?
>> Exactly.
>> If we could always have the right
features, then the problem becomes easy.
>> So that's a lot to learn.
>> Yeah, and to have learned.
What are we going to next time, Michael?
>> Here, I'll give you a hint.
I'm hiding the slide.
We're going to talk about
partially observable models.
>> Hm, okay, that makes sense.
That means that I got lots
of opportunities for puns.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All right, we'll see you there then.
Wouldn't want to miss that.
>> [LAUGH] See it has already begun.
All right well by, Michael.
>> See you, Charles.